[Music]
just add hairstylist to Miley Cyrus's
list of many talents on Thursday her
boyfriend Cody Simpson posted two photos
of his long blond locks on Instagram and
asked followers should i buzz it the
general consensus seemed to be hell no
but what did Cody do the 23 year old
Aussie posted a time-lapse video of his
haircut just hours after asking his fans
for advice in it Miley can be seen
giving her Bo the initial cut before
handing the buzzer over to a friend for
the finishing touches the video was
perfectly set to Swayze's 2007 track
buzz ins as for Simpsons caption buzzin
clean cuts for clean oceans I say the
avid surfer later shared a pic of his
new do on his stories writing buzz 'it
hashtag clean cuts for clean oceans
[Music]
with Miley on my it's a grandchild
typical house things
Reschke cody showed off his new look on
my Lee's a bright minded Instagram show
Thursday I was mad about my own haircut
first time I showed this thing she did
it by the way she did it guys she buzzed
it so it's all her fault
it's always my fault and speaking of
cute
Cody serenading Maile to his song golden
thing is pretty much the cutest thing
we've seen all week now if that doesn't
give you all the fields oh but wait
there's more Cody also read Miley a
freaking poem that he wrote about her
she is the one who swims in the sound
and doesn't burn up your most beautiful
babe I mean the piece is featured in
Simpsons poetry book Prince Neptune
which it drops on April 7
oh and did I mention that the lovebirds
also sang a duet of Daniel Johnston's
true love will find you in the end
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so much cuteness from Miley and Cody the
two first starts dating rumors last
October and when ETF Simpson whether
he's in love while chatting with him in
February he had this to say
wouldn't she likes it I'm just kidding
I don't know it's hard to say it's a big
it's a big call to me I guess only time
will tell but Cody's haircut isn't the
only thing changing during quarantine
just saying of course keep coming back
to et for all things Cody and Miley
until next time I'm Hallie Stevens and
I'll see you soon
[Music]